(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 294
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
This is an exciting episode for me.
As you can see, I'm
perched outside my office,
I have a small group of friends here,
we did a really fun barter party
for the Clouds and Dirt.
So I want to first,
let's clap it up for each other.
(audience applause)
Really nice crew here,
I know we're live on Facebook as well,
we're gonna probably take most
of the questions from here
and I have two wonderful guests here
and I'll explain in a minute why.
One reason is I'm very excited
about doing their event
which we'll bring a
little bit of awareness to
but the gentleman here to my right
with the help of the
gentleman here to my left,
if I could think about how
many individuals are out there,
if one looks back in 20
or 30 years and says,
wow, Crush It was a book
that was written about social media
that really kind of nailed it
and created a blueprint
that I then followed
and created companies, followed myself.
If there's people outside
of me who've executed,
and many of you are in
the process of doing that,
and many of you watching even more so
but if you asked me in 20
years and definitely today,
to speak to the individual or individuals
that best executed against the thesis,
it's very difficult for me
to think of a name better
and doing it longer
and more importantly authentically
from reading actually Crush It
to changing their lives
to then jumping early on
platforms and executing
and then building around it,
it's very difficult for
me to think of somebody
who's done it better than Shonduras.
And so I'm very happy that he's here
so let's clap it up for him on that.
- Thanks man.
Did someone get that on camera?
I need that clip.
(audience applause)
- And so for the
VaynerNation that's watching
and some of the people in here
that may not know who you are,
why don't you two beautiful
men introduce yourselves?
I gave you a little context,
why don't you jump on it?
- So I'm a professional
wrestler going by the name,
no just kidding.
So I started out on social media,
I did the Snapchat thing,
I was one of the first Snapchat pioneers,
did the very first brand
deal with Snapchat,
kept pushing the limits
going from there, built
an entire community,
built the ecosystem for what
was Snapchat brand deals
and how we worked with
brands and partnerships.
A lot of that was through Gary.
From Snapchat, I learned
I wanted to diversify,
get something more scalable,
went over to YouTube,
that seemed more long term
but it still didn't have the
scalability that I wanted to.
So I continue going,
now we have a full
talent management agency,
we're really big into Esports,
we've got space station gaming
and continuing to build other businesses
outside of just social media.
We have a conference coming next month
that Gary's gonna be a speaker at.
- Yeah, when is it?
- Holladay is the guy here
who helped me do all of it.
- Yeah, so VidSummit
is the conference you're referencing to.
In LA, October 9th through the 12th,
Gary speaks on the 10th,
so if you're gonna come, come the 10th.
So a little about myself,
traditional start up guy,
had raised money before with companies,
had made every effort to
get in front of this guy,
would come to these types of events,
try to rub shoulders
with him when he'd speak
and now on stage with
him which is amazing.
So about two years ago,
started with just Shaun,
I literally didn't know
people made money on YouTube.
- He didn't know who PewDiePie was
when he came to work for me.
I'm like, alright, let's dig into YouTube.
So you know PewDiePie and
he's like, "Wait who?"
I was like, "Alright, we've
got a lot of work to do."
- I didn't know who Casey was,
really, really oblivious to the scene.
Came on with Shaun from
a business perspective,
not as much like oh, I want to get famous,
I want to get numbers
and from that business
perspective I had one goal
which was make money and scale.
So we jumped in with Shaun,
started making money and
scaling which was amazing
and then from there,
found that there was so
much overflow off of Shaun.
And so we started picking up,
one of those overflows was from Gary.
So Gary would kick some stuff,
kind of unique opportunities
and invitations
and kind of connections
and then we took and started saying,
wait, what if we worked
with other influencers?
And so we started working
with other influencers
and from there we built
a talent management
called Spacestation Integrations.
Now we work with some of the
biggest talent on YouTube.
- Shaun, talk to me
about the jewelry company
after you read Crush It?
- Oh, I was gonna keep that one a secret.
- Bring it, bring it because
I think it's super important
because I think for a lot
of people that are watching
and for even a bunch of us in this room,
I started off as a wine retailer.
I think the thing that
most people struggle,
and when I look around this room,
all of us have one to
three more chapters in us,
I think people struggle with understanding
how deep the innovation and disruption
that the internet is actually causing.
I think that a lot of
people see the final result
but they don't understand
the steps that take there.
So off of reading Crush It,
what were you doing
and then what did you do next?
- So I was in college
'cause I didn't know what
I wanted to do with my life
but I wanted to do something really cool
and my teacher had me read Crush It
by this guy named Gary Vee or something
so I'm like, alright,
let's read this thing.
Read it, I was like, oh
dang, this is incredible,
I need to figure this stuff out.
So I started running my own business,
which was a skateboard/snowboard shop.
Coolest part about owning a
skateboard/snowboard shop,
you literally just chill
and watch snowboard
videos all day, it's dope.
Worst part about owning a snowboard shop,
you literally just chill
and watch videos all day,
you don't sell anything, it's not dope.
So Crush It helped me realize,
there's so much more out there,
there's different platforms
where you can share a message,
sell a product,
give a service, whatever
and that's when I wanted
to try something new.
So I wanted to figure out the internet.
Internet was killing my sales
'cause everyone bought their stuff online,
free returns, everything else.
So I wanted to figure out
how can I sell skateboards,
snowboards online.
After reading Crush It, I was like,
wait, this isn't the best idea.
This is working harder,
not necessarily smarter.
I love snowboards
but it doesn't mean I need to sell them.
So I really put together a business plan
of what would be the most effective way
to start my first online business.
And I came to the conclusion of jewelry.
It was small, it was lightweight,
there was a huge market for it
and the platform I chose
to build my business on
was Facebook at the time
kind of the very first
social media platform
that really hit hard.
I ran the entire jewelry
boutique under my wife's name
'cause I thought it was a little creepy
like skater kid running a jewelry boutique
out of the back of his shop.
So it was all under her name, rainy day,
alright, ladies, what movie
are you gonna watch today?
And they'd be like, The Notebook
and I'd be like, already seen it.
It got weird, guys,
but it taught me a lot
about building a business
and the power of social media.
So from there,
I was like, oh, this is the real deal,
scaled that in one year,
was able to sell it,
had actual money in my pockets,
paid off student loans
and started what would
be my next business,
which was in social media
and that's where I identified Snapchat
and took it from there.
So from reading Gary's book Crush It
to executing on that,
finding success,
digging deeper
and then I was just bragging,
I'm the very first quote in Crushing It.
So only one person has the
first quote in Crushing It,
it's me.
- Limited real estate, Shaun.
So Holladay, how did you get to Shaun?
So you're a start up kid,
you're playing in that world,
how'd you find Shaun,
what played out?
- Yeah, so little background,
Shaun and I, Shonduras the name
was from a mission that
we went to in Honduras.
So when he got home,
they called him Shaun
from Honduras, Shonduras.
So that's kind of the history of the name.
So we knew each other
there just a little bit,
nothing crazy though.
When I got back,
I was running my start up,
and was super deep
and Shaun was coming into
town for a brand deal
and naysayers like, hey,
can I stay with you?
I don't want to stay at this hotel.
I was like, sure.
So he slept on the floor at my house.
- Whoa, whoa, we didn't sleep,
we stayed up all night talking.
- After we stayed up till four.
- The plan was to sleep on the floor.
- Is that how you rolled back then,
you wouldn't want to go
to hotels, you just like?
- Oh yeah, everything is networking,
connections, old friends.
I saw he was killing it.
He had his own start up
business that crushed it
and I was like, dude, I
want to learn from you.
I'm doing the Snapchat thing,
you did your thing,
let's hang out and jam.
Spent the whole night talking,
next thing you know I'm like,
dude, I'm getting way
deep into public speaking,
I was kind of trying to be
Gary's understudy at the time
and if Gary didn't do a deal,
I would do a deal.
We spoke at a couple of events together
and I was like, dude, I want
to crush public speaking.
His previous business
was an app that turned your
phone into a microphone.
So anyone out there just
pulls out there phone
and asks a question, super simple.
I was like, you know the
speaking world, help me do this.
And he helped me do it.
He helped me get my first speaking gig,
got me a TED Talk,
provided all this value, no payment
and I was like, dude, this guy hustles,
how do I get him on my team?
So I was like, yo, what would it take you
to move you out, you and
your family out to Utah--
- Real quick for everybody watching
and listening on the podcast,
before we started this episode,
with the group of 17,
25 people that are here,
I said, "Look, before you leave,
"make sure you say hello,"
'cause I've been watching
them for the last hour
and a lot of people haven't
said hello to each other.
I love when you,
Instagram is a limiting platform for me
which is why the most
motivational version of myself
is on that platform.
With one minute video being the length
and pictures and quotes,
there's only one part of
what I can show there.
But there's a quote
that I put on Instagram,
it just says, people are the ROI.
And you can only do so
much to explain a post
even with long copy and I do that,
of what that purpose is,
but it's interesting to me
in what I tried to
pressured this room to do
over the next two or three hours
is exactly what you did
which is people are the ROI,
and I think what's super fascinating to me
as we become more and more digital
that sleeping over somebody's house,
the random dinner meet ups,
events like this
and anything everybody in here
or watching or listening right now can do
to put them in a place
with like minded people,
is like disproportionately
the right thing to do.
- Yo, you guys want to
know a cheat code for that?
I've been using this for years
and it works great.
I already used it on
some of you guys out here
so don't get weirded out
but I go around,
talk to everyone I can,
have the most meaningful
five minute conversation
where I'm listening,
I'm not on my phone, I figure
out exactly who you are,
learn from you, become friends
and then I go, oh dang,
is there food around here?
I'm looking for some food,
dude, I'm gonna go find some
food, I'll catch you later.
Then I walk just down start
talking to someone else.
Five minutes, yo, is
there food around here?
I'm trying to get some food.
That way you don't get caught in the 30--
- So wait, real quick,
for all of the people
listening and watching,
in the future when you pull the food card,
that means you're ready
to move on from them?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Okay cool,
I just wanted to make sure.
- I love all of you
but I don't want to talk
to you for 30 minutes.
I want to talk to everyone
here for five minutes
and to end that conversation,
you, is there food, are those drinks?
I'm gonna go check those out.
But you never actually get food,
you just keep hopping around,
that's the cheat code.
- I think for a lot of people
that are listening or watching,
I think not everybody's
extroverted and can do that.
You hear that with his energy
and it's like, cool, that works for him.
I think it's really
interesting to learn skills
or break your habits.
To me, it's one thing to have that ability
to work a room for real,
there's a whole nother thing
that I'm most fascinated by
which is what's happening
here right now physically
which is you're already here.
It's one thing to have that ability,
if you're actually there,
and to me the whole like minded events,
to me, going to a huge networking thing
like business networking, sucks
because it's so, not that it sucks,
it's not as conducive to what I'm trying
to push everybody to do
because the concept is very broad
whereas if you go to an event
that is around an individual
or a very long tail event
like Super Mario Brothers Two,
if you go to a Super
Mario Brothers Two meetup,
everybody's there for fucking
Super Mario Brothers Two.
You should be able to have
a lot of conversations
'cause you're so long tail.
So a business event versus
a cryptocurrency meetup
around one single currency
that's nine weeks old
and there's 15 people there,
if you find yourself introverted,
I can't tell you enough
how important it is
to find the long tail of your interest
because it's gonna make
you feel more comfortable
'cause the context is so deep.
The group might be smaller
but the ability for you to
interact becomes greater.
So it's just something to think about.
Or everyone loves food,
just be like, yo, is there food here?
And start talking to 'em.
- Fair enough. So how did you find him?
So he found you?
- Yes, showed him the house--
- You guys had a slumber party?
- Running, scaling his business
and I remember we wrote
down on this piece of paper
till four in the morning,
here's the verticals of my business,
I'm focused on, for Shaun
it was Snapchat, YouTube
and then he had this
vertical that was speaking
and he's like, I just don't have the time
or effort or team, I
just can't pull it off.
And at the time it was
just him and an editor
and they were doing all this
YouTube and Snapchat stuff.
And so I was running a company at the time
in the event world and I
said, "Let me just jump in."
So Alex, who's in the back here,
was a buddy at the time
and he started helping me
navigate that world a little bit.
And so we got Shaun a TEDX,
we spoke three times right after Gary.
So Gary would speak and we
would go to the event and say--
- He'd warm 'em up and
then I was the keynote.
- So Shaun would speak right after Gary,
all while I'm still running my own company
and I just added value.
So when I came down to,
sold the start up and we were moving on,
first guy Shaun calls is like,
"Yo dude, congrats, come be on my team."
And I had already had 12 months
of connection, hustle, value
and so it was a really easy transition.
We knew how to work with each other,
we knew how to do it
and I never made a
dollar off of him, never.
- So for me, especially
having everybody here,
where I want to transition
into is heavy Q & A
and I'll tell you why.
I think what I'm setting up here,
what my personal kind of mission is
is I'm starting to realize,
especially over the last week or two,
I've been thinking quite a bit about this,
which is the maturity of
building infrastructure
around a personal brand
is pretty remarkable.
If I wasn't running Vayner full time,
I started realizing, my God,
I'd probably have 55 full
time people in GaryVee Inc.
And that means that in 15 to 20 years,
the model of, it's happened,
whether it's an Oprah
or so many other things,
Newman, Paul Newman, and you
can go on and on, Jordan,
I think the long tail of Human Inc.
is far greater than people realize.
I think that we are in the national anthem
of an 18 inning game
of what a business looks like.
I think we've all realized,
especially over the last decade,
oh crap, as a personal brand,
you can speak, you can write books,
you can be a YouTuber and
get tons of pre-roll ads.
I don't think people realize the maturity
of how far this goes
when you go into merch and IP
and just disproportionately I think
over the next four to five decades
we will see 100, 500, four
billion dollar companies
built around a human.
We've seen a couple
be able to do that in
a traditional landscape
but way more important
to everybody watching and everybody here,
how about 100,000?
So for me what's super interesting to me
is how many people in America,
let's just stick with America,
would rip their arm off to
make $100,000 a year, a lot
or more importantly, how many
people make 127,000 a year
being something that they hate
and how much they would
love to make 100,000 a year
being a baker or a candlemaker
or a shoe expert or the
foremost expert on Space Jam.
And so to me, what I'd like to do,
knowing a lot of this audience,
and I'm thrilled Seth
if we want to take questions from Facebook
but specifically here,
let's open it up.
Who's got a question around personal brand
or that thematic, if you're in here now?
Hands.
Let's move the mics, who's got 'em?
Alright, Senan, get your going.
Name and question.
- [Brock] My name is Brock Johnson.
So my question is at what point do you,
so at a certain point you get
one to two people to help you
but then at a certain point
it gets to where it scales
and then it's like you have
to hand it off from being you.
At that point, how do you
transition from zero to one
and then that one to six and beyond
of building the
infrastructure of Human Inc.
like you're talking about?
- Oh I got this 'cause I did it.
I was just me, just Shonduras,
and I couldn't film all
my videos and be talking
and running a new company
and doing all this stuff
so I connected him with everyone I knew,
I gave him access to
everything I had access to
and then I let go of creative control
'cause that's what you have to do.
If I want him to send an email
the way I want to send it,
it's not going to work.
I teach him what my voice is
but then I give him full creative control
and I'll tell you, one of my businesses,
he runs it more than I do.
He knows more about it then I do
and he's scaled it bigger then
I ever thought it would go
because I gave him full control
and then took away my
creative control I guess.
- Thoughts?
- Yeah, I think there's this
certain level of control
but I think the other part
is who is on that team?
Finding the right culture fit,
like Shaun and I are
just best friends from--
- We have the same first name.
- There it is folks.
Just hire people with your
first name and away you go.
It's all billions after that.
Brock's gonna be hard.
- Good luck.
You've met a lot of Gary's team
and a lot of them have the
same vision and culture
and not just ingrained in
them from Gary but from birth.
And some of those assets,
you have to find and have.
And so I would say as far as,
not from one to that,
but finding that one,
I think that one really has to
be ingrained in what you are
and the culture you have
because that one's gonna get two
and then that two's gonna get four
and four, six, eight and on and on and on.
And Gary's good with 900.
But that first couple are
really, really important.
- For me, there's a couple things.
So something interesting has
been happening in my team,
DRock and I, you might've saw,
if you're following closely,
I was garage saleing this Saturday
and Lou, who's not here,
his name is Little Lou to me
'cause I've known him since he was six.
His dad was my friend
in the wine business.
I've literally known I'm since I was six.
He's worked here since he was 18,
he didn't go to college.
He's been here for five, six years,
he's one of my Jets friends,
so he's a real friend
and I just know him extremely well.
He's one of the people I really know.
So he was with us.
If you were hardcore watching,
he was the one holding the
teddy bear up in the background
this weekend when I
found the $20 angry bear.
Anyway, DRock, are you here?
I think this is right.
This is right,
I think Lou, so this Saturday,
is this right Saneen,
you know where I'm going?
I was in the car in between garage saleing
posting on Instagram
like the post was in,
we have a system, like
a text chain, a system,
we have a fucking text chain
where there's a bunch of creative
that we work on together,
there's a lot of the team here
and I picked the one I liked
and I started writing the copy.
And little Lou, who
I've known for 20 years,
who's worked here for the last six,
who's always around,
is like sitting in the back
'cause DRock's in the
front seat and he goes,
"What are you doing?"
And I go, "I'm posting,"
I thought he meant why am
I wasting a few minutes
'cause we have to quickly
get to the next garage sale
'cause we don't want somebody
to take some good shit.
I was like, "Oh, I'm just gonna
quickly post this Instagram,
"I've got to post this."
He goes, "You post your own Instagram?"
So the answer is yes
and I write all the copy
and I think people realize
how bad my grammar is
so I think they understand that
but I still don't think they believe it
or they think somebody does it.
I think the biggest thing that
I think about when scaling
is what do you keep
and what do you let go?
And that has to be individual.
The way you scale is by realizing
five people doing an 80 of your 100
is better than just you doing 100.
And so first and foremost,
it starts with ambition.
So for example, a lot
of people say shit like
oh don't look at Gary Vee,
he has 20 fucking people,
that's why,
but what they don't
realize is first of all,
and Andy, I'm trying to look for you,
but the reality is in its truth
and a lot of the teams here,
in its truth, we could
be remarkably efficient
in doing what we're
doing with six or seven.
The reason I have 20 is
I'm training a lot of them
to infiltrate the overall
organization in the long term.
I have 20 because I want,
'cause Baben right now is working,
has been working, if you haven't noticed
he hasn't been around in the content,
he's working with VaynerTalent,
one of our divisions
and ONE37PM is something I
have enormous ambition for,
whether it's Saneen or Syd, Jake,
there's so many people on the team here
that I know can go and dominate there
but I'd like them to get incubated
for six months to a year or two
and really fucking know it.
So my ambition is to buy the New York Jets
and so creating scale and
being inefficient with 20
and we are plenty fucking inefficient
with the amount of people we have,
and that's why everybody's smiling,
is still ROI positive
because I'm gonna scale them to the 900.
I think you need to know
what your ambition is,
first and foremost
and then I think you need to hold on
to what you value the most.
I on Instagram and Twitter,
every single one of those posts are me
and I need it to be me
and I have to have it be me
and it means a lot to me that it's me
and that's what means something to me.
And so that's just the way it is.
So I think you need to think
about what you want to
be doing with your time
and what you value
and then you start
building a team around you
that has complementary
skills to the things,
and I go one of two ways,
either they're very like you,
and for me, to what you mentioned,
I saw people shaking their heads,
to me, where my team
has to be very like me
is they have to be nice.
Not super complicated,
I'm completely suffocated in negativity.
Thus, if I'm the fucking engine,
I don't care if somebody's
the greatest growth hacker
or can design, is fucking Pablo Picasso.
If Pablo Picasso's a
fucking dick, he's out.
That's what has to be like me.
Everything else has to be not like me,
like you have to be able to read an email
and many other things.
And so I think that ego
is what holds back people from growing.
They like the feeling,
in companies, and personal
brands are tough 'cause it's you.
So I'm not comfortable with
somebody writing on my behalf.
I have to say everything I say.
Every piece of content
is transcription from my words.
People are like, I
always read the reviews,
they're like, oh my God,
this book sounds just like
you, Gary Vee. I'm like, right.
It's literally, the ghost writer
is just making it grammar.
It's transcriptions.
So I think that's what
you have to think about.
- [Brock] Okay, so I
don't have to feel guilty
about my Slack channels just
being really unorganized?
So you really focus on
speed and people like you.
- Yeah, to me, you need to be you.
Everybody's gonna always win most
if they lean in more to what they are
instead of trying to do something
that they see somebody else doing well
and be ideological about it.
In art and sports,
we've accepted that we're
not Lebron or Beyonce.
For some reason in entrepreneurship,
we have this false feeling that we can be.
We have not layered the talent card
into the entrepreneurial creative land
to the level that I think we need to.
Everybody just thinks
that they're gonna make a
million dollar business,
that it's so easy
in a way that we don't with
putting out a rap album
or playing basketball
and that's a day of reckoning
that needs to happen in this
space to help everybody.
For me, I'm only comfortable in chaos.
There's a report card
hanging there in my office
for a couple reasons.
One, I just think it's hilarious
but more importantly, I'm
not going to be organized,
that's not what I get paid to do,
that's not who I am.
I feel no bad about that whatsoever.
I want to find people
that are comfortable in our organization,
and I'll tell you, Andy,
who's my right hand, the guy,
I've watched him, not get less organized,
I've watched him and
everybody else on my team
prioritize better
because they start off more organized
and then I systematically in osmosis
take out of them to
not focus on dumb shit,
even though they're the one in charge
and they have to care more than I do.
But no, I don't think you
beating yourself up around your DNA
is such a negative exercise.
What you need to do is figure
out what you naturally do best
and quadruple down on that
and then build infrastructure around it.
I genuinely believe that, the end.
That's why I love Q & A.
That's why I struggle with
some of the stuff I put out
because I hate that I
can't have full context.
It's why I love Q & A. I need the context.
The best advice I give are
the people I know the best.
Questions?
Yep, here I'll give you mine.
- So your personal brand is
- Who are you,
and where are you from?
- [Alan] Oh, my name's Alan
Baruby, I'm from Saco, Maine
and I was wondering about
you branding your name.
So did you just say, hey
I'm gonna brand my name?
Was there another business
idea that you thought
maybe it was gonna be the brand instead?
'Cause it really puts a
lot of emphasis on you
and when you brand your name,
you're kind of stuck with that, right?
You can't change it?
- Here give me this real quick.
You can't change it as in,
to me I love the name because
I actually think it gives you
disproportionate
flexibility to do anything.
As a human, if you go from
wine guy to social media guy
to whatever you want to do next,
I think it gives you that flexibility
whereas if you're like the photo expert
and then you want to write,
you're like, oh fuck.
So when I look to people go
literal with their brands
versus I'm Sally Thompson or Rick Jones,
I think sure you need to do a little work
but what I mean by little work
is your actions become your brand.
If you go read the early,
if you go back to 2009
and go on Twitter,
people shit on me for
but you're the wine guy,
you can't start a social media agency.
I'm like why?
I'm like over time my actions
will make me that brand.
Today, way more people
know me as an entrepreneur
than they do as a wine guy.
But the first year of my
existence and the transition,
I got shit on at scale
for making that transition
but that's like Marky Mark
becoming Mark Wahlberg.
The Rock is less of a wrestler today
than he was 10 years ago.
So what I always tell people
is whatever you are now,
your execution's gonna define you.
So to me, I'm not scare
of it for that reason.
- [Alan] And you didn't get
stuck to be the wine guy,
you just wrapped everything
around wine at that point,
I guess Gary Vee could be
anything at that point?
- Yeah, and I think again,
there's so much that goes in,
there's so many funny,
first of all, the Gary Vee
thing is really funny to me.
First of all, it's a terrible
name in the way I spelled it
because there's two silent E's.
It's just a bad idea for a brand.
Number two, it's funny how it went down.
I tried to register for Twitter
four months earlier than the
first time I registered for it.
Literally I saw it and I
tried to register for it
and the wifi in London didn't work
and I just was like fuck it
and I got back to it four months later
and the first time I had just Gary
and the second time it was taken
and I never, talk about
I love how life works,
in my life, I had never, ever
tried to register Gary v-e-e,
I don't even known where it came from,
I have no idea why I did it
and it ended up being fucking Twitter.
Plurk and Shmirk and
all the other MySpace,
all the other shit, Friendster,
but this was the one that put me on
and then that became me.
So I didn't think about the brand name.
Names to me,
when I watch entrepreneurs and individuals
think about names too much I laugh
because I'm like, what does Facebook mean,
what does Nike mean?
Nothing means shit when it first starts.
The execution defines it.
McDonald's is a Irish pub, right?
So it's the execution.
And so that's how I think
about branding your name.
If today you're a lawyer
and in four years you want to be a clown
and then nine years later
you want to be the
foremost expert in bourbon
it is your execution and your talent
that will define that over time
I the same way that Justin
Timberlake isn't from N'Sync.
Your skills are what predicate the outcome
and I think people get caught up in a name
which is a quick tell of not
seeing what actually plays out
when building brand.
- I didn't even choose my name,
it just kind of happened
and then I've had to roll with it
but I could choose my
mantra, what I'm all about.
I have the best day ever
and I give everyone high fives
and I'm always positive and
that's what I could decide
and that's really all that matters.
The name just kind of comes
with the Shonduras, Dr. Duras,
I might get into medical, I
don't know, whatever sticks.
- Questions?
Who's got the mics?
Go ahead, go ahead.
- [Emory] Hey, my name is Emory
from Charlotte, North Carolina.
My question is what was your biggest
internal or external struggle
with building your brand
from the beginning,
when you were just starting out?
- Hey, we talked for five
minutes before I got food,
what's up?
- [Emory] We did, what's up?
- For me it was that scalability.
Most of my first business ventures
were very heavy on me
and it wasn't until I met Holladay
that I didn't realize
it's not just a matter of working
harder and working harder,
you need to build a team.
And we just talked about
how to do that correctly
and that was my number one
thing that was hard is because
and you noticed earlier I stressed
giving away creative control.
It's because for me, that
was the hardest thing
because I am a creative
and I want my videos to look like this
and my emails to look like
this and everything else.
And I'm like Gary,
I have the things that, my
social media's me, I post that,
but everything else I need
to have a team backing me
and I need to trust in my team,
I need to train them to do what I think
is right for the company.
But when it comes down to it,
they need to do what their gut check is
and I need to trust them on that
and Holladay's made so many decisions
that I had no idea what was happening
and they've all worked out to be amazing
and now we've scaled multiple
businesses side by side.
- All of them?
- 100%.
- Andy's made like three good ideas
and 900,000 wrong calls.
So my answer's pretty interesting.
I think you'll find it fascinating.
I sat on the idea of, DRock was like,
we gotta vlog, we gotta vlog,
Casey's the best blah, blah, blah
and I was like, I'm not
gonna fucking, I'm too busy,
I'm busy, very minute is programmed,
I'm not gonna walk around with a camera.
And so when it came to huh,
should I have DRock follow
me around and film it,
it was no question
one of the biggest challenges for me to go
because don't forget, this
is now three plus years ago
and the thought of now
look what's going on
but it's not super complicated,
this is what's so fun about the internet
is everything's documented,
people weren't rolling with
somebody else filming them,
people were rolling like
Roman and small cameras.
Just even having the handle felt big.
These were small cameras, right.
That was vlogging.
And so I'm like, oh, I'm gonna
introduce a man following me
and filming me at all times.
I knew that 98%,
and don't forget,
forget about being a
creator and an influencer,
I'm an actual business C-suite executive
going to meetings
with 58 year old conservative
C-suite executives
and like here's Drock,
he's filming this meeting.
That was super unaccept,
or walking down the street.
So it was a really interesting
conversation with myself
for about a month
of holy fuck, I think
I've figured this out.
If he films me, I can
make unlimited content.
I'll have a vlog,
I'll be able to have articles,
I could do a podcast,
it all came to me pretty quickly
of like this is the gateway
to unlimited being a media company.
Film everything,
and the first place I went
is this is gonna be fucking amazing
because my grandkids are gonna watch this.
The next place I went
is everybody's gonna
think I'm a dick face.
It's gonna take me a good year
to have to eat shit
where everybody thinks I'm a
douche bag and a narcissist
but I'm completely convinced
everyone's gonna do this,
that everybody who can't hold it
is gonna have somebody film them
and literally told DRock in episode one,
dude, in four years,
we're gonna be sitting in meetings
where everybody's gonna have a film person
filming the person.
There's gonna be six people in the room
in a three person meeting
and it's when it started
happening 18 months ago or so
we kind of had some good chuckles.
But basically, almost everything
I've done in my career,
when I was an 18 year old kid
and I'm pushing to launch a website
for my dad's liquor store,
and we're part of a liquor co-op
and everybody wants us
to open a second store,
I knew everybody was gonna shit on my idea
of selling wine on the internet,
something they didn't even know existed
or was a fad at best.
So for me, business decisions, struggles,
the macro has always been cake,
I'm an entrepreneur,
I don't give a fuck about
what anybody thinks about me,
I'm good in life, game over.
In the micro, which is far more secondary,
which is why I push so many
people to not give a fuck
'cause then everything becomes easy,
it's an everyday thing.
There's 46 things I'm
struggling with right now.
- [Emory] Awesome, thank you.
- Yep.
Let's push it back there.
- [Lizette] Chef Lizette, New York City.
Okay, so I love the tactical questions
and I really want to get
all of your perspectives.
Literally from my life,
I'm gonna break it down,
I have a job, super grateful.
So if you were building your brand today,
day one, you have a job, a great job,
you need to be responsible to that job--
- How many hours do you
have a day to yourself?
- [Lizette] 10.
- To yourself?
So if you have a job,
before I can answer for sure,
I'm gonna need to know how
many hours does your job
take out of your day?
- [Lizette] Well it takes 10.
The job takes 10,
I need to sleep six, I need seven,
but six is great.
- No it's just seven fucking
hours is a lot of hours,
I'm excited already, keep going.
- [Lizette] But I work seven days.
- Yeah, you have 10 that you
work, seven that you sleep,
and seven hours in a day
that are yours to do shit.
- [Lizette] No, but I'm
saying I go seven days.
- I got it, you've got 49
hours a week to do damage.
- [Lizette] Exactly.
- So what would you guys tactically do
to make more money
or where would you prioritize your time?
You're talking about building brand,
I'm a chef, I've been doing it 27 years
so I'm trying to get to the next place,
retire as a chef professionally
and move to the next spot,
whether it's a show,
whether it's scaling myself.
- But is the next spot financial
or is it something that you've--
- [Lizette] Well it's legacy, it's legacy.
For me, it's legacy.
You don't invest 27 years
without thinking about
what I've already invested as a chef.
So it's legacy dominated
so it's not about the short term money
but it is about the money
because how do I eventually
retire as a private chef,
as a chef period
so that I can focus
100% on building brand?
So tactically I want to know
what would you guys do if you were me
with 27 years deep--
- Lizette, real quick,
you were saying that,
I just want to make sure I
understand this question,
you're saying that you want to retire--
- [Lizette] Because it takes up 10 hours.
- So you're saying
you don't want to be a
private chef anymore.
- [Lizette] Correct.
- Okay.
- [Lizette] Yeah, physically
it's just, it's enough.
- I understand.
- So how would you do it?
It's hard to imagine you guys being a chef
but try to put yourself--
- Be careful, I'm about to fucking--
- [Lizette] No, no, no.
Okay, let's go, I'll bring you in--
- Don't challenge me 'cause I'll fucking--
- I make a mean bowl of cereal.
- [Lizette] No, no, no but
just put on the chef hat
and every little dynamic that I gave you,
what would you do with that?
How would you take that and go?
- So I actually have
a client that's a chef
and Instagram, he's got 450,000 followers,
Facebook, 1,000, YouTube,
500, Twitter, 50.
- Why's he got 450 on Instagram,
for real, don't bullshit me.
- Because he knows what fits
on Instagram.
He makes it on a wood
kind of like this look,
it's this rustic kind of,
Dennis The Prescott's his name,
love him, he's amazing
but he knows burgers stacked
with cheese falling works--
- [Lizette] How long has
he been on Instagram?
- Two and a half, maybe three years.
- And for real, for real
because this matters to me,
why did he explode?
Did he have a viral post,
did influencers put him on,
like Shonduras and Tanner Fox,
did he buy ads?
What's the punch line?
- Some of it was organic
and he played into the
audience that he had
which was a female.
And so he knew who he
needed to connect with
within that world.
At the time, he had
kind of a Facebook type
group type situation.
- Andy, I apologize,
for real, the 400,000 to 4.2 million,
when I got fucking pissed on
that vacation and got serious,
how big of a factor was 60 second club?
First I started posting
more with hashtags.
Did I immediately go out
and start doing JV with
shoutouts from other posts
or was it content?
I mean 60 second club was
insanity when I first did it.
It was just a tactic that I came up with,
like seriously real talk,
that was the first thing that got,
I remember doing that,
'cause that was December,
I went on the vacation,
I was still in, I went off
the grid to the island,
then I was in Florida
and already came up with 60 second club
'cause I was really giving a fuck
and that really worked at the time
because the algorithm favored
that many comments in
that short of a time.
- [Andy] Yeah, I would
say it as a trifecta
of that first happening,
shout outs and then realizing
how big the content,
shares, more content.
- But I think also, if Gary's,
if Gary went down some of
my other clients I work with
and he did Orbies and pranks,
you see him coming out
of his glass office whoa,
I have clients that that
does five million views.
For Gary that doesn't work.
You guys don't care about--
- Be careful, I'm about to
prank the fuck out of you.
Give me a snake.
- So you have to feed into your audience.
- [Lizette] But your chef dude,
did he have a cookbook as well I think?
- So he released later after
he had gotten some traction.
So I think Dennis as the example,
just the point is find
what fits in your audience,
find what they like and keep feeding them.
If you notice his every fifth,
fourth post is a burger.
- Lizette, I'm telling you right now
'cause obviously we've known
each other a long time,
I swear, and I've been
watching enough to know,
I literally think you should flip shit.
Out of all the things
watching you try to do different things,
when you tried to buy
those printer cartridges
when I saw that I was like, yes.
I'm like this is going to be her,
if she really,
to me, nothing on Earth right now,
take 100 people that
have talent or interest,
and say, you're gonna be a personal brand
and make $100,000 a year.
Right, 100 people, have interest,
into Star Trek, can be a
chef, can be into wine,
sneaker, music authority,
whatever you want to be,
100 people, go be an influencer
that makes 100,000 a year
from branded deals, speaking
and being that human like we do.
Take that same 100 people
and say, retail arbitrage,
go to TJ Maxx, go to thrift stores,
ready, the 100 people, every 100 people,
one, two, as an influencer,
get to 100,000 a year,
50 get to 100,000 a year flipping stuff.
- [Lizette] So don't be
romantic about what I sell,
just sell, just sell?
- Period, period.
If you're tired and you want
to get to the financial freedom
of not having to do something
for 10 hours a day--
- [Lizette] Well but no, no, no,
you know the cost to this,
the minute I stop earning money as a chef,
and let's say I get to the 100K, right,
I've sold my tail off,
I have the 100K,
that goes really quick
if you're now getting a DRock,
this is the part I don't know.
- No, no, I think you're
missing the point.
I think you should just,
once you make the 100K
with TJ Maxx, thrift
stores and garage sales,
while you're still a chef
in your seven hours a day,
posting on Etsy and
Craigslist, packing, real life,
once you do that,
you don't quit being a chef
and start trying to build
being the chef brand,
you go and take those 10 hours
and make 430,000 a year flipping stuff.
- [Lizette] So what is
the timeline that I say,
I have a 24 month plan
to not be a chef anymore.
Is that how you work it?
- Well, let me tell you how I did it,
I think people are completely
utterly fucking confused
on how zero amount of money I had
when I was 34 years old
and started VaynerMedia.
If I had money,
I wouldn't have started the company
in somebody else's conference room.
I did it,
I had to rely on the
$100,000 a year salary
I had from Wine Library
while I was building Vayner
'cause this wasn't giving me any money
in the first two years.
So I had to live back and forth.
When you're siphoning off of something,
the time limit is whenever the threshold
of you making enough to
get you off the other thing
based on your overhead.
So do you need 100, do you need 47?
If you're in a rent controlled
apartment in New York,
that person can do it easier
than somebody who isn't.
There's so many variables.
- [Lizette] Well okay,
so the wrinkle to that
is I'm a live-in chef
so that's a huge,
I don't pay rent in New York,
just imagine that, that's huge.
- Are you fucking kidding me?
It's humungous.
- [Lizette] That's huge.
And I do that on purpose.
- As you should, it's a smart move.
I think, I'm gonna say it again
and I'm saying, I'm
obviously giving you advice
'cause I've been watching
but this is advice for everybody else,
the amount of people
that are talented enough
to make 100,000 a year
being a personal brand
is more than people think
and less than people think.
And one has to be self
aware to figure it out.
You've been hacking at it for awhile.
I think it's quicker for
you to get to a hundo
by thrifting and flipping, I just do.
When I tell you that I'm
watching this all go down,
let me tell you one place
that I think you could play in.
I'm unbelievably fascinated
with fashion and jewelry
because my game is nostalgia.
So I'm really good at buying
the fucking teddy bears
and the video games
and the stuffed animals
but they have a tangible value.
When Justin and I look them up,
like oh fuck, this South
Park piece of doody's $27,
you look that up.
The people that I think
have the biggest advantage
in the flip game,
are people that have an eye,
that can go to a thrift store,
it doesn't have to say Knicks Championship
or OP or polo, it just looks cool
and they're like that's cool
and I'm gonna just merchandise it
on Etsy or Let Go and Mercada
and whatever in this way
or I'm gonna buy this brooch
for 25 cents at this garage sale
'cause it looks vintage retro,
I know how to write the copy,
I know how to make it look fresh
and I'm just gonna price it at 69.99.
Listen, you guys have all seen it
if you're paying attention,
I can't get off of these,
there are people who do it for real
but the people that going
from zero to 50 or 100,000,
I can't get it out of my
mind of how real it is
in a world where most Americans
don't make 100,000 a year.
I don't know what else to say.
Yeah.
- [Alan] I got a buddy that in the spring,
we live in Maine,
in the spring, he buys, Alan Baruby,
Saco, Maine, again,
he buys snow plows and snow blowers
and in the fall he sells them
and he's killing it,
I'm telling you,
and it's a lot bigger scale
than a thrift but it's--
- If you buy basketball stuff
on Ebay in the off season
and then repost if when
the season starts up again,
there's a 20 to 40% delta.
If you go to stores when
they have sales or closeouts
or are closing,
you know how many people
could've made $100,000
just by going to Toys'R'Us,
loading up when it was
going out of business?
The utter arb,
I like the thrill of the hunt,
I don't want scalability in flipping
'cause it doesn't get me off.
I don't want to buy
5,000 things from China
and sell them on Amazon Marketplace,
that's not what I want to do.
I've lived that game,
I sold a billion dollars
worth of wine, fine,
that's buying and selling.
I love going and finding
strawberry shortcake for 25 cents
for nine bucks, I'm like
this is the fucking greatest.
But if I wanted to make real money,
there's so much in retail arbitrage
it's almost utterly uncomfortable
and if you're a creative person
who really just loves buying
and selling tee shirts
from thrift stores in America at scale
is just imperpetuity,
especially if you know how to write copy
and get an eye and really start learning.
And then eventually,
I was doing this before you had a phone
and could look up shit.
So I memorized everything.
I'd go to garage sales
and be like, nine, 17,
14, 23, four, seven, nine, 13.
Me and AJ were joking this weekend.
I called him 'cause I can never,
outside of going to Jet games
there's nothing more fun for me
and I always ask him this.
I'm like, bro, what would happen
if I just went off the
reservation and retired
and just did this?
I'm like, how much do
you think I could make,
I always ask him that.
And it was funny,
he's like, dude, I think in a year or two,
you'd make millions
and I'm like, yeah, because
really what I would do
is just buy a bunch of trucks
and just buy out everybody's garage sale.
And that's my way.
The much better way,
but by the way,
I'm trying another better way right now.
Just out of my own curiosity,
I've been buying a bunch of
bulk magazine type stickers
and different shit on Ebay
and just going to relist
them on Amazon Marketplace
just to learn to give people,
this has been such a fun
content pillar for me
because it's my hobby
but no thing I've ever done
has made more people that
needed more money than this
because I'm not trying to do it
like some people who do it
for hundreds of thousands or millions,
10,000 extra a year for
somebody that really needs it
is like insanity and it's sitting there
and the Craigslist free,
watching people,
what's weird about Craigslist Free
is you have to be a real gangster
because shit's big.
It's not like buying a bunch of stuff,
you have to be willing to get a truck
and pick up a fucking video
game for free and resell,
but people, my whole
thing is like, listen,
you know, this is funny,
I never talk about Dover, New Jersey.
I lived in Dover for a year
before we went to Edison
and I never even, I always
wonder why I don't bring it up,
I'm like, we went from Queens to Edison.
It's not true, we went from
Queens to Dover to Edison
and it's really interesting.
I've been asking myself lately
why did I not happen,
why did I just say that?
And maybe 'cause it's a year
or maybe it was the first time
I ever talked I just said it
and then that became the thing
but it was interesting,
it was a really tough
time in my life that year.
I got picked on the most
'cause I couldn't speak English,
I remember a very scary event
with my dad with kidney stones
so that always scares me,
I always still get freaked,
but it was a very hard time,
we didn't have a car.
Me and my mom, we used to,
sometimes I talk about it, walk
three fucking miles to Kmart
and what I think about that time
or how my sister,
literally, my sister when we
first came to America in Queens
everything she owned
came from the garbage.
My sister's fucking thing
that she sat in as a baby
was a car seat that my cousin
Bobby found in the garbage.
We brought a car seat
into our studio apartment
and she sat in it.
And so when desperate times,
desperate measures, fuck,
this Craigslist, Ebay, free,
come to my house, take it,
and repost to 50,000 a year
if you're just willing to bleed
and don't give a fuck
that you're walking around town
with TVs and strollers and humidifiers
and cinder blocks.
- You can get palates
on Amazon of returns.
So you can buy a returned
palette from Amazon
and it comes
and some of 'em don't work
and some of 'em are okay
but some of them are amazing.
They just open the package
and like, I don't want this
and turn it back and you can--
- We've obviously spent
a lot of time on this.
One out of 100, 50 out of 100,
that I can't, whether
that's right math or not,
that's my intuitive answer to
that question, that's crazy
and what I really like about it
is my biggest thesis is if
you love something you'll win.
The fact that you can sell everything,
allows everybody to love something.
I know waffle makers
make a fuck load of money on the flip.
I know in garage sale culture
finding waffle makers, right Justin?
Calculators kill,
the bottom line is everything kills.
Everything is there for the taking,
you just have to fucking want it
and I love when every time,
I've been tweeting about it
a lot and doing a lot on it,
people are like, yeah, but
what about the Ebay fees
and the shipping, I'm like you
charge the customer shipping.
- I think an overlaying
theme here is creativity.
We talked about the jewelry boutique
that I started literal first business.
I had $400 in the bank, I didn't
know I was gonna start it,
I didn't think it was gonna be a business.
It was just an experiment
to learn how to do stuff online.
I hit up the companies and said,
"Hey, I'm a big time jewelry guy,
"I'm gonna be launching a huge boutique.
"Can you send me some of your product
"so I can see what the quality is
"to see if I want to learn more?"
My first 100 sells were
necklaces they sent me
to check out the quality
and then from there, I
had made another $400
and then I started doing small orders.
I didn't do my first order
until two months into the game
with my actual money.
I just got creative.
- The thing that blows me away
is the people that have the
least ability to be fancy
are the ones that are the most fancy.
Beggers can't be choosers.
I love doing dirt shit.
People give me excuses
all the time like ah,
you have no leverage.
You want more money,
you want to get to the next step,
you have to do whatever.
And people are like,
I'm not fucking waking up at six o'clock
to go through somebody's garbage.
I'm like, cool, sit on your fucking coach
and complain on Twitter that this is fake.
These are the interactions,
and you don't see a lot of stuff,
I'm DM'ing people like,
you're a fucking loser,
you're sitting here
saying this is bullshit,
here's everybody that's real as fuck.
- If you want a DM from
Gary, just complain.
- It is true.
The person that says no with no knowledge
is the greatest tell to a losing DNA
and so I just think
people are fancy out here.
People are fancy out here
like they're gonna be VC backed
or they're gonna be fucking Casey.
Go fucking make $50,000
selling tee shirts.
It's literally right here,
it's in your fucking face.
Retail arbitrage
is something they will
talk about in 50 years
'cause the data's so disgusting.
You have to be super basic
and you could make money.
- Important.
- One more question, we're out.
Here.
We'll do two more.
- Hi, Rabia Sutton.
So my question is more around
back to the conversation
of the transition.
So you had a jewelry store,
you're doing stuff for
your family business
and when you decided to kind of embark
on the personal brand
and what those first couple of steps were?
- For me, the first couple of steps were,
don't forget how long ago it was,
it was acknowledging its existence.
And so again, we just
spent a whole lot of time
saying one out of 100 versus 50 out of 100
but for me, knowing a
little bit about you,
you're a prime,
where I think Lizette
has to make decisions
on what's the right move
'cause I want to get off this thing?
You have a business
and now it's like layering on top of it
versus I want to get off my business.
And maybe you do in the long term
but I think every one of
us has different things,
like I wanted an identity
outside of something,
I needed that.
Now it's for me to talk about.
At the time, it was subconscious.
Knowing what I was doing
for my family business
and knowing that the narrative
was gonna be I was put on
when I felt like I was putting on.
I was like, I need something else
to make this very clear to the world
what the fuck was going on
and that was my own shit.
We all have our own shit.
I think for you,
you have so many things.
Personally, here's the transition,
you have to create content.
You're set 'cause you
have stuff, you have stuff
and again, same with Lizette like others,
this is the great,
being a minority woman today
is like the great advantage,
your timing's amazing.
You do, it's just the truth.
There's a lot of interest in it,
there's need for it,
there's demand for it,
it's like more doors are open than ever,
that's just fucking facts.
So you need to run through them
and not say shit, that was the one window.
I was just telling these guys,
I'm like, I never talk to Steve Ross.
Steve Ross is my business partner,
he achieved what I want,
he owns the Dolphins and they're
three and o, those fuckers.
He's the best dude ever, best,
literally I'm like fuck,
that's what I'm gonna be,
that's how I see it, just the best.
I talk to him three hours a year.
I don't talk to him at all.
And once in awhile when I talk to him,
and it's just fun,
it's not even like mentorship,
it's just like I love him.
I walk out of there every time,
right Alex, three fucking hours a year,
never, I never talk to him
and every time I walk out I'm like,
dude's 78 and I hope he lives to 1,000
but I always leave there I'm
like, I'm a fucking idiot,
one day I'm gonna be like,
man I should've spent 100, 500 extra hours
with this incredible man,
you're gonna do the same thing.
This is your golden era right now,
it's happening right the fuck now.
There's never been a
better time to be you.
You've done it
and you've got the optics
that the, unlimited demand,
you cold email Forbes and
Fast Co and everybody,
they're interested.
And guess what?
It will go away, just like everything else
and you're gonna be like,
fuck, I had a window
from late 17 to 21 and I
didn't fucking squeeze it.
No different than
Facebook and Instagram ads
that I always cry about.
You need to produce content.
The transition is write
a fucking LinkedIn post
about what was difficult
or how the government merged
or how you do it or what you thought,
knowing what I know.
- [Radia] Okay.
- One last one.
- [Max] Alright, so my name is Max Maxwell
from North Carolina as well.
- Max Maxwell.
- [Max] Max Maxwell,
man if my name was Max Maxwell,
I'd have at least four
million more followers.
Go ahead my guy.
- [Max] So I took your
advice 10 months ago
started documenting what I do.
I'm a real estate
investor, kind of exploded.
Now it's like I'm at the point
where real estate's stuck for me,
I'm an entrepreneur by heart
but you throw shit at the wall
and that's what happened and worked
but I feel like I'm being boxed in
as the guy that talks about real estate.
- But Max Maxwell, we
just answered this one,
until you start talking
about beard oils or watches
or fucking kicks or wine or the Redskins.
- [Max] So how do I make that,
so I want to talk more--
- Just make the content.
- [Max] Just start doing it?
- Listen, this is where I always talk
about watch, you know how I'm always like,
I don't know if you know,
watch what I do, yeah,
everyone's like you can't do that.
I'm like, why?
In the fucking real estate episode,
whatever you want to talk about next,
throw it in and watch what happens.
People are people.
In real life, we like
each other for the layers.
Yeah we might be homies
because we both liked that video game
but then later we find out
we both love root beer floats
and riding bikes.
I don't understand how
people don't understand this.
People are so ingrained,
you know what it is, man?
This is all about ideology.
Everybody's in their own fucking, right,
we're all stuck in our ideology.
Oh, I'm the real estate dude,
I can't, I don't know make your next,
dude, I'm out there buying
shit at garage sales
and flipping it.
Do you know how insane that is to people?
Do you know what kind of weird
emails I get from my friends?
They're like, yo, are
you okay, are you good?
You know you're ruining,
so I literally just ran from here,
I was literally just
at the Google building
with Eric Schmidt and the
president of Cuba, right,
that's where I just was before I--
- Same.
- So one of the homies
that's in that meeting's like
literally this weekend was like,
dude, on Monday you're gonna
be at Google headquarters
with Eric Schmidt and
the president of Cuba,
and today you're out garage saleing
at seven in the morning
buying people's old trash?
What are you doing?
And I texted him back and was like,
yeah and last night I was with Sam Darnold
at a super hot spot in New York City
and more people came up to
take selfies with me than him.
I'm like, this is my life.
And guess what?
Mike Vacanti, you know
Mike, my old trainer
if any of you know?
He texted me and he's like,
yo, my mom just called me.
She just had to call me and say
her favorite content of yours
is when you're garage saleing.
It's definitely the
place I'm most creative
and I take a still shot. I
don't do that shit normally.
I'm like trying to be out
there like a real creator.
I'm like oh, I fucking missed it,
it didn't work out,
leaving New York.
You could do whatever the fuck you want
and for the 13% that ditch you
because they're like,
yo, I'm here for real estate Max Maxwell,
don't be talking to me about sneakers,
you're gonna pick up 29% that are in
and net score, you're gonna win
because the biggest advantage we have
is I'm real estate dude,
I love fucking snow globes,
I love the Raiders, I eat pizza,
my brother's my best,
the advantages we have are the layers
and everybody's trying to sell vanilla
when everybody wants to buy chocolate.
I'm selling it 'cause I'm chocolate
not just like I'm one thing.
We're missing the layers.
Everybody's trying to vanilla themselves
into like I'm the cryptocurrency gal
and you're an awesome sister
and you're great at skiing
and you have thoughts about
Tiger Woods coming back
and you love, you're a foremost expert
on peanut butter and jelly.
You see what I mean?
Go ahead.
- I think that a lot of
people are watching you
'cause they dig Max Maxwell.
So you need to tell the people your story,
why are you moving to the next thing
and why should they come
and why is it gonna be interesting?
I think if you build this
rapport with your audience
over the next couple days, weeks
and then transition
them to something else,
they're gonna come because they love you,
not just real estate
and there's maybe people
that are watching you for real estate
but then they learn what a baller you are
and you're doing X, Y or Z over here,
they want to learn more about it
and they get motivated
and then that audience comes
and then you become friends with them
and then you move on to the next thing.
I went from jewelry boutique to Snapchat
to YouTube to Esports,
those things aren't connected--
- Downloads of your contents dad's.
- I'm a family vlogger.
I used to be a skateboarder.
- You have selling
on the streets Gary,
you have CEO Gary.
- Back to the other thing,
but there is no dad Gary
'cause that's a thing we
decided to go the other way.
So it's not everything,
you gotta be you.
I went completely private
on the family part.
Everyone's doing their own thing
but that's your strength
and your uniqueness
and to Shonduras' point,
he's probably right about
build it up and convert.
I'm just like fuck them,
just make a barber video out of nowhere
and they're like, what the fuck,
am I on the right channel,
is that Max Maxwell, what
the fuck? It all can work.
- That's true.
- It just can all work
and I think people are overthinking it
and they self identify
but I think we're going too vanilla
and I'm trying to push
creators and vloggers
and individuals and businesses
to show all the layers
because there's people that
literally bought my sneakers
'cause I'm a Jets fan,
literally that is the single reason,
not I made content for them,
not that they associate
with entrepreneurship
but we're a small little community
and we're mad at everybody
and he's a Jets fan,
so fuck it, I need a new pair of sneakers.
You gotta give people
more reasons, not less.
And you weren't even
that guy 10 months ago.
So again, we're overthinking
and by the way, let me give
you some real good news,
nobody gives a fuck.
You know why everything works for me,
We get way too serious on ourselves.
If I tomorrow start
being the Play-Doh dude,
at the end of the day,
everyone who's sad here,
like fuck I really loved
when he did business content,
I'm not about this Play-Doh life,
I promise you this
when I go fully into Play-Doh and 24/7,
there's no business for you
and you're like, fuck that sucked
'cause we loved it,
you'll all leave and do your thing,
I promise you a month later,
you'll forget I ever,
maybe 'cause it was good for you,
you'll go back and watch
your favorite episode
or piece of content
but like it's gonna be okay.
And I really started realizing that
when iconic people were
dying in the last five years,
I watch
and I'm like fuck,
and I say this often,
if Prince only gets a day and a half,
then nobody gives a fuck, Max
Maxwell, you know what I mean?
If Prince only gets a day and a half
before everybody moves on
and nobody gives a fuck,
well then we better get real serious
about what the fuck are we really
and realize, I navigate every day
knowing nobody gives a fuck
and so thus it makes me
very easy to do my thing
and let the chips fall.
And I think that level of humility
to go along with the confidence
to do whatever the fuck you want,
that contradiction, that's
where all the fucking magic is.
Like hoo, you can't make that transition?
'Cause what, somebody's
gonna leave a comment
and be like, yo, I fucking came here,
I subscribed for that real estate stuff.
They do that to me all the time
and I'm like, cool,
there's nine trillion more of that coming
and there's nine million in the back
and there's other people feed you,
today it's about fucking
buying Barbies and flipping it.
- [Max] Cool, thank you man.
- You got it.
Cool, thank you so much everybody here.
I'm looking forward to jamming with you
now in a few minutes.
Everybody watching, thank
you for listening or watching
the #AskGaryVee Show,
no even question of the day,
we're just wrapping it up.
This one totally different tune.
Thank you so much, Shonduras, Holladay,
thank you so much, see y'all.
- Bye.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)